Wie ist Frau Bauer?
32 Jahre.
32 Jahre?
Am 23. Mai 1992.
1992.
1993.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Bauer?
Ich habe mich jetzt lange nicht gemessen.
Ich glaube, 1,73 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ca. 65 kg.
Frau Bauer, haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Also bisher bekannt ist nichts, weiß ich nicht. Normalerweise nicht.
Wie ist der Name Ihrer Hausarztin oder Ihres Hausarztes?
Das ist...
Wir alternieren sehr, Frau Schmidt.
Ich bin 35 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren? Könnten Sie mir Bescheid geben?
Wir waren am 15. September 1989 geboren.
Ich schuldige Sie, ich konnte nichts verheißen.
Am 15. September 1989.
Danke schön. Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin 1,70 m groß.
Wie viele wiegen Sie?
60 kg.
Und könnten Sie mir sagen, wie heißt Ihre Hausarztin oder Hausarzt?
Das ist die Frau Paul.
Frau Paul.
Und wann sind Sie? Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Büro als Spirationskauf-Frau.
Spirationskauf-Frau.
Was ist Ihre Hautbeschwerde, Frau Schmidt? Könnten Sie mir in ein paar Sätze beschreiben?
Ja, ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich wieder Bauchschmerzen habe, wieder Blähungen habe und wieder Durchfall habe.
Bauchschmerzen, Blähungen und Durchfall.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 5. Juli 1961.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr 1,70 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 95 kg.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarztin oder Hausarztin?
Dr. Schäfer.
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 11. Juni 1968.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Ich bin 168.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so seit?
79 kg.
Vielen Dank.
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
42 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Am 1. Juni 1982.
Ich bin 72 m.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
75 kg.
Was führt Sie so?
Wie kann die Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 24 Stunden
schon seit gestern habe ich Übelkeit erbrechen und auch ein bisschen durchverlehrlich gemacht.
Ja, Herr Müller, wer sind Sie? Ich bin 42 Jahre alt. 42, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. Januar 1982. Ok, wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin ein Mitte 72 groß. 72? Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Und wie ungefähr 75 Kilogramm? 75 Kilogramm. Ja, Herr Müller. Ja, wie alt sind Sie, Frau Seif?
Ich bin 60 Jahre gerade. 60 Jahre? Ok, wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 1. März 1965.
Wie viel wiegen Sie und wie groß sind Sie? Also ich wiege so 70 Kilogramm.
Und ich bin 1.460 groß. 1.460. Und wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 74 Jahre alt. 74 und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 22. August 1951. 1951, ok. Herr Stein, wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit? Ich wiege momentan circa 95 Kilogramm.
Und wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1 Meter 75 groß. 75 groß, ok, alles klar. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder
Ihr Hausärztin? Doktor Schmidt. Doktor Herr Schmidt oder Frau Schmidt? Frau Schmidt, ok. Danke schön.
Frau Ort, wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin genau 68 Jahre alt. 68. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Am 25. Mai, 1900. Wie bitte? 1957, ja. Ja, genau, 1957. Danke.
9.007. Nein, nicht 900. 1957. Ok, wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1 Meter 75 groß. Ja, wie schwer sind Sie?
98 Kilo. 98 Kilo, ok. Was für Sie, so uns Frau Ort? Ich bekomme nicht gut Luft und ich kann nicht mehr laufen.
Was meine Sie? Ich bekomme nicht gut Luft und ich kann nicht laufen.
Frau Lindemann, vielen Dank. Wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 58 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. Mai, 1966. Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie? Ich bin 1 Meter 60 groß und wiege zur Zeit 68 Kilo.
Z. Ok. Und wie alt sind Sie? Noch bin ich 34. 34. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 18. Mai, 1990. 90. Und wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1.86. 1.86. Und wie viel wegen Sie zur Zeit?
Ich wiege so 98 Kilo. 98 Kilo. Und wer ist Ihr Hausarzt?
Frau Luthers, wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren? Am 23. April, 1979.
79. In dieser Monat gibt es Ihre Geburtstatemier. Genau.
Und wie groß sind Sie? 1 Meter 72. Und wissen Sie Ihre aktuelle Gewicht?
Ja, ich war heute Morgen auf der Waage. Das sind 85 Kilo.
Ok. Können wir Ihre Beschwerden anfangen?